well let's get more on that breaking
news on brexit and the Windsor framework
uh let's talk to our political
correspondent Rob Powell who can join us
now from Central London and um and Rob
the dep did have their concerns about
the Windsor framework now they've really
made it very very clear what they are
yeah I think this will be a
disappointment there was maybe a bit of
hope that the least the dup maybe would
sit on their hands and abstain when this
vote comes to the commons on Wednesday
it's essentially a vote on one part of
Rishi sunax new brexit arrangement for
Northern Ireland but it's very much been
presented by Downing Street as a sort of
vote on the whole deal and a chance for
MPS to have a say on the whole deal and
what the dup have said in the last half
an hour or so their leader Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson has issued a statement
um saying that in their view whilst The
Windsor framework does uh represent
progress actually it doesn't deal with
as they put it some of the fundamental
problems at the heart of our current
difficulties and they say they need
further clarification and it needs
further reworking and a change as well
as seeing another legal text now at the
core of their concern is the fact that
um whilst one part of the Windsor
framework the so-called storm on break
it will be able to be applied to any new
EU law that will be be potentially
applied in Northern Ireland because
remember Northern Ireland under the
brexit agreement will remain a lot
closer to the EU to make sure that the
border on the island of Ireland stays
open the dup's issue is that actually
this this break doesn't apply to EU law
that is already in force in Northern
Ireland because Northern Ireland has to
be a lot closer to the European Union
there is still some Euler or EU law
albeit a smaller amount than was
previously applied that companies
manufacturers have to follow in the
country so that is there in in Northern
Ireland sorry so that is their key
problem here essentially that they say
that this new deal doesn't address that
now what does this mean for Rishi sunak
in terms of his vote on Wednesday well
in reality
um he won't it doesn't make any
difference to whether he's going to win
or lose the vote labor have already said
they will vote with the government but I
think what it does do is potentially
increase the scope for a bigger
Rebellion amongst his own conservative
MPS were expecting conservative back
bench brexiteers to publish their own
legal view on this they've been
Consulting with lawyers and solicitors
about this over the last month or so we
know they have concerns on this as well
I think a lot of them were maybe looking
to the dup to sort of take their lead
and if the dup had been broadly on board
or abstained then maybe they would fall
in line or be more likely to fall in
nine as well I'd suggest now that this
means that actually more conservative
back benches May well vote against Rishi
sunak all of that said I don't think the
Rebellion is necessarily there we're not
necessarily going to likely to see the
size of rebellion that we saw under
Theresa May in previous brexit battles
but more potential here to cause the
Prime Minister a headache I think
potentially also the bigger practical
impact is that if the dup aren't happy
with this deal they may well decide to
continue their boycott of going back
into Power sharing
um in Belfast so that may mean that the
devolved executive the devolved assembly
may still not be able to sit in Northern
Ireland of course that means that the
Democratic institutions that are
supposed to be overseeing Public
Services there that have been out of
action for over a year now may still not
get up and running but it also means
actually that this key part of the
brexit deal the storm won't break is
basically rendered useless because it
can only be used if Stormont is sitting
so that will potentially cause problems
as well and maybe be the bigger
practical impact flowing from the dup's
decision
um not at the moment anyway to back
Rishi sunax refresh brexit deal